this video was made possible by
brilliant learn with brilliance for 20%
off by being one of the first 200 sign
up at brilliant stone org slash went
over a single aircraft carrier is enough
to markedly change the level of a
nation's military might these ships are
one of the strongest single assets a
military can have in general under
international law aircraft carriers can
legally position themselves up to 14
miles or 22 kilometres from any
country's coast clearly the strategic
influence of being able to place a
military airbase just miles from any
coast in the world is enormous
especially given that 80% of the world's
population lives within 60 miles or 100
kilometers from the ocean while plenty
of military vessels are capable of
launching helicopters there are just 19
aircraft carriers worldwide currently in
service capable of launching fixed-wing
airplanes China Thailand India Russia
and France each have one Italy has two
and the US has the 11 largest in the
world
these largest carriers require over
6,000 people to operate and often stay
deployed for up to a year they are fully
fledged cities at sea the most advanced
aircraft carriers like the French Navy's
Charles DeGaulle are capable of
launching an aircraft every 30 seconds
that means that for a brief period when
launching aircraft at its maximum rate
the aircraft carrier Charles de Gaulle
becomes busier than Charles de Gaulle
Airport in Paris to be able to achieve
such a capability on a moving ship is no
easy feat while the operation of these
vessels gives militaries enormous
strategic advantage they also represent
one of their greatest operational
challenges an aircraft carriers
offensive weapon is its aircraft on
board carriers tend to only have a small
number of defensive weapons such as
surface-to-air missiles and machine guns
but of course just like any powerful
military asset these carriers are big
targets it is for this reason that
carriers never travel alone while on
deployment
well the exact composition can change
depending on the mission two Carrier
Strike groups American carrier travel
with are typically made up of a guided
missile cruiser equipped with tomahawk
missiles two guided missile destroyers
an attack submarine and a supply ship an
aircraft carrier is the flagship of this
strike group meaning that in its command
area it not only has a bridge and an air
traffic control center it also has a
flag bridge
when admiral commands the entire strike
group each of the group ships serve some
combination of offensive and defensive
roles the only exception is the supply
ship most aircraft carriers don't need
regular fueling all 11 American carriers
and the French one are nuclear-powered
meaning they can sail an unlimited
distance for 25 years without refueling
even conventionally powered aircraft
carriers like the UK's HMS Queen
Elizabeth can travel up to 12,000 miles
or 18,000 kilometers without refueling
making the need for stops infrequent
while an American or French carrier
could hypothetically sailed non-stop for
years or even decades what they can't do
is carry enough food which is always
needed an aviation fuel which is needed
for combat operations to stay at sea for
more than a few weeks at a time it would
be inefficient and place the carriers in
a position of vulnerability to have to
visit a port every few weeks to restock
especially during combat operations so
they don't they restock while at sea the
supply ships that move as part of the
strike group will sail off to a nearby
port to take on fuel ammunition food and
mail sail back to the Strike Group then
match speed and maneuver longside the
carrier from there the two ships will
shoot lines across to each other these
lines are used to pull hoses over to the
carrier which are used to transfer
aviation fuel to transfer solid supplies
there are two methods the first is
attaching pallets to dollies that wheel
cargo over to the carrier like a zip
line the second method which is
considered simpler yet more dangerous is
using helicopters to pick up pallets
from the resupply ship and flying them
over to the carrier these transfers
bring both crucial supplies like food
and some less crucial items like mail
but this isn't the only way mail arrives
on American aircraft carriers each
carrier actually has a mailing address
just like any building in the US for
example this is the USS Gerald R Forge
address families of sailors can send
mail to these addresses in the same way
that they could to any other and in fact
it cost the exact same as a shipment to
any other US address even if the ship is
on the other side of the world sailors
can even order packages online to their
ship expedited mail often makes it from
an address in the US to a carrier
sailing somewhere around the world in
just 10 days
having this speed requires more frequent
deliveries than those of the logistic
ships but conveniently carriers are
airports at sea American carriers
currently use a fleet of c2 greyhounds
as cargo aircraft providing a high
frequency often daily connection between
carriers and Shore when cruising in the
South China Sea for example as the USS
Ronald Reagan did in November 2018 mail
might be sent to Singapore by
conventional means a c2 Greyhound would
then fly from the ship to Singapore pick
up the mail and fly back to the ship as
carriers sail around the world the
pickup points of the c2 greyhounds are
continuously shifted to nearby friendly
nations while mail does wonders for
increasing crew morale that's actually
the lowest priority cargo for the c2
greyhounds the aircraft are integral for
bringing on spare parts for all the
carriers aircraft and transporting VIPs
press and other individuals to and from
the carriers the c2 Greyhound is about
the same size as an Embraer 145 a
civilian aircraft capable of carrying 50
people so it's not tiny the longest
aircraft carrier in the world which also
happens to be the newest is the USS
Gerald r4 but even she is only 1106 feet
or 337 metres long with commercial
airports a runway of 5,000 feet or 1,500
metres like the one at London City
Airport in London is considered short
while large airports like London
Heathrow will have runways longer than
10,000 feet or 3,000 metres so how do
you see two greyhounds and other
aircraft on carriers deal with having
runways of only 1,100 feet or 330 metres
long they don't they take off with just
325 feet or 99 metres of space all US
and French carriers use a system of
catapults to get aircraft up to takeoff
speed within three to four seconds this
allows these carriers to launch a
decently sized aircraft like the c2
Greyhound with their relatively short
decks other carriers like the Chinese
and Indian ones don't have catapults so
they can only launch lighter shorter
range aircraft capable of taking off
with a very short runway both these two
types of carriers have arrestor wires
that aircraft catch on landing to
decelerate with a short distance given
every other aircraft carrier out there
can only operate with aircraft capable
of vertical landing what takes place on
the flight deck is carefully
choreographed chaos on American carriers
everyone's job is easily identifiable by
the
color shirt they wear yellow shirts deal
with navigating aircraft around the deck
blue shirts are assistants to yellow
shirts driving tugs operating elevators
delivering messages and more red shirts
to all the handling and mounting of
ammunition purple shirts manage aircraft
fuelling green shirts are worn by a few
different groups including catapult
crews maintenance personnel cargo
handlers and more white shirts are also
worn by a mix of personnel including
those helping aircraft land working as
medical personnel and more and lastly
brown shirts are worn by plane captains
or not those that fly the aircraft
they're individually in charge of
overseeing all work for getting an
aircraft ready for flight the flight
deck is a dangerous place given its
small size it's so small that all the
carrier's aircraft can't fit on it but
of course just below the flight deck is
the hangar a large carrier can carry up
to 100 aircraft so massive elevators
bring aircraft from the flight deck to
the hangar for storage when not in use
about 6000 people work and live aboard
each American carrier 3,200 of them have
jobs related to running the ship itself
that includes everything from working in
the engine room maintaining the nuclear
reactor cleaning the decks to actually
working up in the bridge commanding the
ship many of these jobs are below deck
and since all the above deck space is
used for flight operations many on board
can go weeks without seeing sunlight
2,500 other personnel are part of the
carrier's Air Wing if this was an
airbase on land these would be everyone
working there including air traffic
controllers aircraft mechanics fuelers
pilots and more the few hundred
remaining personnel work assorted other
jobs in terms of personal space enlisted
personnel the vast majority of those on
board only get a single bunk in a room
with sometimes more than a hundred
others higher ranked individuals though
of course have more spacious
accommodations as long-term homes for
thousands of people
these ships also have a few small
luxuries like stores gyms barber shops
lounges and more the space is at a
premium when six thousand people are
packed into one floating Hall and the
mission is paramount since their heyday
in World War two some have started to
question the place aircraft carriers
have in modern warfare every operating
country aside from the US ten to at any
given moment have their ships either in
combat in training or at home the u.s.
tends to use as carriers for a fourth
function power projection
at any given moment there is almost
certainly an American carrier cruising
somewhere in the world in fact January
2017 was the first time since World War
two that there was not an American
aircraft carrier on deployment even if
there wasn't an aircraft carrier on
deployment they're fast they have a top
speed of 35 miles or 56 km/h meaning
that in Norfolk Virginia based carrier
kick it to the middle east in just a
week in the Pacific the US has an even
greater advantage since it has the USS
Ronald Reagan based in Yokosuka Japan
from where it could reach the shores of
North Korea for example in just 29 hours
American carrier spend plenty of time
just cruising around the world's oceans
reminding other countries of the USS
military power
for example the USS Ronald Reagan
returned from a four-month deployment
from August to December 2018 during
which it's all zero combat it spent much
of the time cruising around the South
China Sea an area in which China is
attempting to assert military control
much to the us's displeasure elsewhere
in Asia American carriers also regularly
make visits to the Korean Peninsula to
remind North Korea of their presence
this reached a peak in November 2017 as
tensions with North Korea reached a peak
when three American carriers loomed near
Korean shores with their enormous power
though aircraft carriers represent an
enormous target especially in the era of
stealthy drones and precise missiles the
sinking of a single US aircraft carrier
could result in more American military
deaths than the entire Iraq war in
addition to the loss of tens of billions
of dollars in military assets wellnot
aircraft carrier of any nation has been
sung since World War two it's
potentially more possible than one would
think US carriers regularly participate
in war games where combat conditions are
simulated with allies there have been
two concerning incidents in 2005 and
where Swedish and French submarines
respectively have won the games against
US carriers what this means is that the
two countries submarines approach close
enough to the carrier's where they could
have if they were an enemy in real
combat launch torpedoes and potentially
sank the carriers this in essence proves
that aircraft carriers with all their
defense are not as unsinkable as some
may say meanwhile the US has already
received the first of 10 in a new class
of carriers while China India
and the UK each have carriers under
construction so despite their possible
obsolescence we can be sure that the
aircraft carrier won't be leaving the
world's oceans anytime soon I have a
logic question for you suppose there are
two doors and the first is a sign on it
saying if this door is safe the other
door is deadly if that sign is false
what do you know about the doors which
are deadly and which are safe take a
moment to think about it and if you
figure out the answer leave it in the
comments this is a question from
brilliant Auguste logic quiz which
teaches you analytical skills through
logical puzzles that's just one of many
superbly designed courses on brilliant
through which you can learn about dozens
of topics including group Theory
multivariable calculus statistics number
theory machine learning and more they're
experts in teaching scary complicated
subjects in a way in which you can
actually understand them by breaking
them down into their fundamental
principles get started learning with
brilliant for free at brilliant star org
sites Wendover and then the first 200
that go to that link will get 20% off
their annual premium subscription